- SO, WHAT'S THIS BIG,
IMPORTANT NEWS?
- YEAH, WOODY,
WHAT ARE WE DOING--UHH!
- YES!
- [gasps]
[bubbling]
♪
OH, MY GOD.
SHE'S COMPLETELY HEALED.
- AND MY RASH IS GONE.
- I WONDER
IF IT CURES BITCH.
[splash]
♪
- I THINK MY HYMEN
JUST GREW BACK.
- DON'T WORRY.
IT'LL BE GONE AFTER HAPPY HOUR.
- RANGERS, OLD WOODY
HAS DISCOVERED A MIRACLE.
AS YOU CAN SEE,
THIS LAKE CURES ANY AILMENT,
FROM THE COMMON COLD
TO CANCER.
- YOU COULD HAVE
JUST TOLD US.
- YEAH, SURE,
BUT THIS WAY WAS MORE FUN.
- HOW WERE YOU SURE
IT WOULD WORK?
CONNIE COULD HAVE--UHH!
[gunshot]
- I COULD GET USED TO THIS.
- THERE MUST BE
A SCIENTIFIC EXPLANATION.
- YEAH, ASSHOLE,
THERE IS.
I WAS CHOSEN BY GOD
TO HEAL THE SICK.
- AND ANOTHER REASON
NOT TO BELIEVE IN GOD.
- THE LORD WORKS
IN MYSTERIOUS WAYS,
AND RIGHT NOW,
HE WANTS ME TO BE RICH.
SICK PEOPLE, LOST SOULS,
DEEP POCKETS, BLAH BLAH BLAH.
RELIGION EQUALS MONEY!
NOW, WE'VE GOT
A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
- WORK? YOU WERE SUPPOSED
TO TAKE ME SNOWBOARDING TODAY.
- SORRY.
NO TIME, CUBBYKINS.
DADDY IS GOD'S PROPHET NOW,
AND I DO PLAN TO PROFIT.
- YEAH. ANOTHER SCAM
THAT'LL BLOW UP IN YOUR FACE.
I WANT TO SHRED THE SLOPES
LIKE SHAUN WHITE.
HE GETS LOTS OF ASS
FOR AN UGLY WOMAN.
- SHRED THE SLOPE?
YOU'VE NEVER EVEN SEEN SNOW.
- WAIT.
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN SNOW?
- COULD SOMEBODY EXPLAIN
TO THE DIVERSITY HIRE
THAT BEARS HIBERNATE?
THAT MEANS SLEEP
FOR A LONG TIME, DENZEL,
SOMETHING YOU SHOULD BE
FAMILIAR WITH.
- TAKE IT EASY ON DENZEL.
HE'S HAD A ROUGH DAY--UHH!
[gunshot]
- WHAT'S WRONG, DENZEL?
- EVER SINCE I WAS
A LITTLE BOY, I HAD A DREAM.
AND THEN,
I REALIZED THAT DREAM.
AND NOW--
[gunshot]
[screams]
- SORRY, I COULDN'T LISTEN
TO ANY MORE OF THAT.
- GOD, THIS WOULD BE
SO MUCH MORE SATISFYING
IF THAT LAKE WASN'T THERE.
- CONNIE, STEVE,
GO ROUND UP EVERY SICK,
GULLIBLE, EMOTIONALLY NEEDY,
DUMBASS, LONELY LOSER
WITH A BANK ACCOUNT.
DENZEL, ETHEL, TAKE MALLOY
UP THE MOUNTAIN TO SNOWBOARD.
STAT!
- SO, THAT'S IT?
YOU'RE GONNA EXPLOIT
THIS LAKE?
- EXPLOIT THE LAKE AND HELP
THE SICK AND DISABLED.
IMAGINE WHAT THEY'LL DO
WITH A NEW LEASE ON LIFE.